what would you like to do if money were
no object then you have what you call
fear you have also precisely the same
sensations that you have in a totally
opposite situation and its enormous ly
important especially for American people
to understand that there is absolutely
no possibility of having any pleasure in
life at all without skill the motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in modest surroundings
and being fascinated by far-east culture
to writing over 25 books including the
way of Zen and making Eastern
philosophies popular in the West
he's Alan Watts and here's my take on
his top 10 rules of success also if you
want more advice and writers like george
RR martin powell aquario JK Rowling and
others check out my to 54 writers wisdom
series where every day for the next 254
days I will send you a morning message
for free to help you build your
confidence as a writer the link to join
is in the description below I've been
reading a lot of historical fiction
there may have been in the back of my
mind it's not enough to know what you
want you have to to do what you want to
be what you want the knowledge that you
have emerged wiser and stronger from
setbacks means that you are ever after
secure in your ability to survive
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one do what makes you itch what would
you like to do if money were no object
what would how would you really enjoy
spending your life well it's so amazing
as a result of our kind of educational
system crowds of students say well we'd
like to be painters we'd like to be
poets we'd like to be writers but as
everybody knows you can't earn any money
that way or another person says well I'd
like to live in out of doors life and
ride horses I said you want to teach in
a riding school let's go through with it
what do you want to do when we finally
got down to something which the
individual says he really wants to do I
will say to him you do that and forget
the money because if you say that
getting the money is the most important
thing you will spend your life
completely wasting your time you'll be
doing things you don't like doing in
order to go on living that is to go on
doing things you don't like doing which
is stupid better to have a short life
that is full of what you like doing then
a long life spent in a miserable way and
after all if you do really like what
you're doing it doesn't matter what it
is you can eventually turn it you could
eventually become a master of it the
only way to become a master of something
to be really with it
and then you'll be able to get a good
fee for whatever it is so don't don't
worry too much that's everybody's
somebody's interested in everything and
anything you can be interested in you'll
find others along but it's absolutely
stupid to spend your time doing things
you don't like in order to go on
spending things you don't like doing
things you don't like and to teach your
children to follow in the same track
rule number two conquer fear I would
like you to consider a mild but
nevertheless chronic form of suffering
which we constantly undergo the
experience of fear what is fear what in
other words
when you arraign are you actually
feeling a great deal of the doctrine of
primitive Buddhism as we have it
recorded from the buddha's own teachings
is concerned with close attentiveness to
one's inner feelings and states of mind
a careful watching of them to find out
what they really are and supposing then
you're afraid what happens to many
people when asked this question seems
strangely unaware their thoughts are
concentrated on the particular
imagination of the feared event
happening in other words a person is
afraid of having a certain sickness
disease and he keeps thinking of what it
might be like to have that disease but
supposing we switch our attention from
that and concentrate for a moment on
what it simply feels like to be afraid
we find don't we that we get a kind of
creepy feeling up the spine we get a
sort of sinking or hollow feeling in the
pit of the stomach and a clammy
sensation in the palms of our hands
now as a matter of fact that's not
really very painful is it that's that's
all that's the matter with you and
that's the worst that life can do to you
at that moment furthermore notice
something else that when you have what
you call fear you have also precisely
the same sensations that you have in a
totally opposite situation when you have
what we call shudders or thrills of
delight they are the same shudders the
same tremble sometimes even the same
creepy feeling up the spine the same
sinking feeling in the pit of the
stomach that a very profound positive
emotional experience can excite so that
we find that our feelings depend for
their valuation as to whether they be
positive or negative very much as to the
context in which they occur as an
illustration of this I might turn to a
very extraordinary work of art
it is a sculpture of Saint Teresa by
Bernini look at that face and try and
decide what feeling that place is
expressive is it agony is it a rapture
of delight which would as we say cause
one almost swoon
what is it actually if you look back and
see the whole sea you will see that the
saint is confronted by an angel who is
piercing her with a dart the dart
representing the divine love and so the
figure represents Saint Teresa in
ecstasy in profound joy rule number
three develop skills discipline is a way
of expression say you want to express
your feelings in stone now stone doesn't
give way very easily
it's a tough stuff and so you have to
learn the skill or the discipline of the
sculptor in order to express yourself in
stone so in every other way whatever you
do you require a skill and it's
enormously important especially for
American people to understand that there
is absolutely no possibility of having
any pleasure in life at all without
skill money doesn't buy pleasure
ever look if you want to get stoned
drunk and go out and get a bottle of
bourbon and dammit you can't do that
except for people who have practiced the
distillers art you can't even make love
without art where I live in Sausalito we
have a harbor full of them ever so many
pleasure craft motive cruises sailing
boats all kinds of things and they never
leave the dock all it happens with them
is their owners have cocktail parties
there on Saturdays and Sundays because
they discovered having bought these
things that the discipline of sailing is
difficult to learn and takes a lot of
time and they didn't have time for it so
they just bought the thing as a status
symbol so in other words you can't have
pleasure in life without skill rule
number four live fully now my goodness
don't you remember when you went first
to school you went to kindergarten and
in kindergarten the idea was to push a
lot more so that you could get into
first grade
and then push along so she could get in
a second grade grade so on going up and
up and then you went to high school this
was a great transition in life and now
the pressure is being put on you must
get ahead you must go up the grades and
finally be good enough to get to college
and then when you get to college you're
still going step by step step by step up
to the great moment in which you're
ready to go out into the world and then
when you get out into this famous world
comes the struggle for success in
profession for business and again there
seems to be a ladder before you
something for which you're reaching all
the time and then suddenly when you're
about 40 or 45 years old in the middle
of life we wake up one day and say ah
I've arrived
and by Joe I feel pretty much the same
as I've always self back I'm not so sure
that I don't feel a little bit cheated
because you see you a fool you are
always living or somewhere where you are
and while as I said it is of tremendous
use for us to be able to look ahead in
this way
there is no use planning for a future
which when you get to it and it becomes
a present you won't be there you'll be
living in some other future which hasn't
yet arrived and so in this way one is
never able actually to inherit and enjoy
the fruits of one action you can't live
at all unless you can live fully now
rule number five let go of attachment to
be detached from the world in the sense
that Buddhists and Daoists and Hindus
will often talk about detachment does
not mean to be non participative you can
have a sexual life very rich and very
full and yet all the time be detached by
that I don't mean that you just go
through it mechanically and have your
thoughts elsewhere I mean a complete
participation but still detached and the
difference of the two attitudes is this
on the one hand there is a way of being
so anxious about physical pleasure so
afraid that you won't make it that you
grab it too hard
[Music]
that you you just have to have that
thing and if you do that you destroy it
completely and therefore after every
attempt to get it you feel disappointed
you feel empty you feel something was
lost and therefore you want it again you
have to keep repeating repeating
repeating repeating because you never
really got there and it's this that is
the hang-up this is what is meant by
attachment to this world in an evil
sense but on the other hand pleasure in
its fullness cannot be experienced when
one is grasping it I knew a little girl
to whom someone gave a bunny rabbit
she was so delighted with a bunny rabbit
and so afraid of losing it that taking
it home in the car she squeezed it to
death with love and lots of parents do
that to their children and lots of
spouses do it to each other they hold on
too hard and so take the life out of
this transient beautifully fragile thing
that life is to have it to have life and
to have its pleasure you must at the
same time let go of it
[Music]
and then you can feel perfectly free to
have that pleasure in the most gutsy
rollicking earthy lip-licking way one's
whole being taken over by a kind of
undulating convulsive ripple which is
like the very pulse of life itself this
can happen only if you let go
rule number six appreciate your
competitors if you wipe out your
competitor then you have no reason to
produce anything but a lousy product and
then you may make lots of money because
he wiped out your competitors you've got
the whole market then you've got this
money what you're going to buy with it
well you there's nothing to buy accept
other people's lousy products
it'll wiped out their competitors or who
treated the public by packaging the
thing to look elegant but it was nothing
inside that's all you've got to buy so
naturally if you're a success in General
Motors you've gone buy a Rolls Royce
from England or you go and buy a
Mercedes from Germany because they
happen to be better cars rule number
seven understand change from one point
of view change is just too bad
everything flows away and there's a kind
of sadness in that a kind of nostalgia
and there maybe even a rage go not
gently into that good night but rage
rage of the dying of the light
[Music]
this is the nature of change if you
resist it
you have dukkha you have frustration and
suffering but on the other hand if you
understand change you don't cling to it
and you let it flow then it's no problem
it becomes positively beautiful the fact
that things are always running out the
things are always disappearing has some
hidden Marvel in it the Japanese have a
word you again
Yug en which has no English equivalent
whatsoever
you again is in a way diggin change its
described poetically you have the
feeling of you again when you see out in
the distant water some ships hidden
behind the far-off Island you have the
feeling of you again when you watch wild
geese suddenly seen and then lost in the
clouds you have the feeling of you again
when you look across Mount Tamalpais and
you've never been to the other side and
you see the the sky beyond you don't go
over there to look and see what's on the
other side that wouldn't be you again
you let the other side be the other side
and it evokes something in your
imagination but you don't attempt to
define it to pin it down
so in the same way the coming and going
of things in the world is marvelous they
go where do they go don't answer because
that would spoil the mystery they vanish
into the mystery but if you try to
pursue them you've destroyed you again
rule number eight know what you really
want son Paul said that the laborer is
worthy of his hire and I as a
philosopher mere philosopher know
dealing in higher things always insists
that I be paid for my work and I get the
highest fee I can get and people say
well you're just out for money
I say that's none of your business
because I give most of it away my own
needs being extremely simple although I
enjoy good food I don't even own a
television set and you know it's a very
simple knife but I've got enough and
enough is as good as a feast you see a
lot of people don't feel happy unless
they have another thing beyond money
which is called status and status to a
very large extent in our economy
consists in conspicuous consumption in
having this thing and that thing and the
other thing and having a swimming pool a
Ferrari a certain kind of clothes and
certain kind of house with an enormous
round style picture window and so on and
so on and so on and we think we need all
that because we've been persuaded by a
certain kind of propaganda that that's
how we ought to live because we haven't
asked ourselves whether that was what we
really wanted
in other words we've been propagandized
into thinking what we wanted rule number
nine understand the true purpose of life
I would like to see if you could change
on basic notions of economics and I mean
the economics of energy we are always
scrimping and saving because our
economics are based on scarcity rather
than exuberance but notice that the
economics of nature are allegedly
wasteful they're based on exuberance
many more scenes than are necessary for
trees many more spermatozoa than are
necessary to people many more stars than
anybody could conceivably want galaxies
galore nature is a vast celebration of
energy but if you complain about this
and say oh dear me it's all running out
that means you see that you are looking
for fulfillment in time and you say if
there is not enough future we won't get
the golden goodie we are looking for at
the end of the line see there is that
feeling there is the great golden goodie
but
that flower that golden goodie isn't at
the end of the line you're in it the
radiating petals the mandala the great
circle of the flower is the galaxy in
which you live it is the whole universe
radiating around you in which you are
[Music]
and this radiation is also cycling it's
the dance in which you're involved if
you'd only realize that the purpose of
life is not in the future and if you
think it is you'll go on and on and on
looking for it there and never find it
because the future in its own way fades
out in the same way as the past fades up
you get older and older and older and if
you don't come crash you just peter out
it wasn't there and you may feel vaguely
cheated about the whole thing you were
given the come on that there was
something coming there was that thing at
the end of the line the golden goodie
but you've been sitting in the middle of
the golden goodie all the time and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is observed it all
comes down to this basic question that
human beings have for a long long time
being concerned about transforming their
minds is there any way in which one's
mind can be transformed or is it simply
a process which is nothing more than a
vicious circle
I could ask why have you come here this
afternoon what were you looking for
would it be too presumptuous of me to
say that you were looking for help that
you hoped you would hear somebody who
had something to say that would be of
help
relevance to you as members of a world
which is running into the most intense
difficulty a world beset by a complex of
problems any one of which would be bad
enough but when you add together all the
great political social and ecological
problems with which we are faced they
are appalling and one naturally says the
reason why we are in such a mess is not
simply that we have Ronald systems for
doing things whether they be
technological political or religious but
we have the wrong people the systems may
be all right but they are in the wrong
hands because we are all in various ways
self-seeking lacking in wisdom lacking
in Courage afraid of death afraid of
pain unwilling really to cooperate with
others unwilling to be open to others
and we all think that's too bad
it's me that's wrong and if only I could
be the right person is this man going to
tell me something that will help me to
change myself so that I will be a more
creative and cooperative member of the
human race I would like to improve let's
look at this thing from another point of
view which you will at first think
highly depressing that's supposing we
can't do anything to change ourselves
suppose we're stuck with it now that is
the the worst thing an American audience
can hear there's no way of improving
yourself because every kind of culture
in this country is dedicated to
self-improvement so here's the situation
you see
there is no that the whole idea of
self-improvement is a is a will of the
wisp and a hoax that's not what it's
about let's begin where we are what
happens if you know if you know beyond
any shadow of doubt that there is
nothing you can do to be better well
it's kind of a relief isn't it seeing
that there isn't really anything we can
do to improve ourselves or to improve
the world if we realize that that is so
it gives us a breather in the cost of
which we may simply watch what is going
on watch what happens
nobody ever does this you know and
therefore it sounds terribly simple it
sounds so simple that is almost looks as
if it isn't worth doing but ever just
watched watch what's happening and watch
what you are doing by way of reaction to
it just watch it happen and don't be in
a hurry to think you know what it is you
think this is the material world
well that's somebody's philosophical
idea or maybe you're you think it's
spiritual that too is somebody's
philosophical idea this real world is
not spiritual
it is not Material the real world is
simply
[Music]
so could we look at things in that one
name without as it were fixing labels
and names and gradations and judgments
on everything but watch what happens
watch what we do now see if you do that
you do at least give yourself a chance
and it may be that when you are in this
way free from busy particles and being
how to improve everything that your own
nature will begin to take care of itself
because you're not getting in the way of
yourself over time you will begin to
find out that the great things that you
do are really happening
I've got a really special bonus skip
from Alan Watts on how to wake up that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing question it's time
to move from just watching another video
to taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what
attachment do you need to let go of
number two what new skills do you need
to develop and number three how can you
live more fully now
by being aware of being aware being able
to represent what goes on fundamentally
in terms of a system of symbols such as
words such as numbers you put as it were
two lives together at once one
representing the other the symbols
representing the reality the money
representing the wealth and if you don't
realize that the symbol is really
secondary it doesn't have the same value
no people go to the supermarket and they
get a whole carload of goodies and they
drive it through and then the clerk
fixes up the counter on this long tape
comes out and you say thirty dollars
please and everybody feels depressed as
they they give away thirty dollars worth
of paper but they got a cartload of
goodies they don't think about that they
think they just lost lost thirty dollars
but you've got the real wealth in the
card all you parted with was a paper
[Music]
because the paper in our system becomes
more valuable than the wealth it
represents power potentiality whereas
the wealth think oh well that's just
necessary you got to eat
I mean that's to be really mixed up so
then
if you awaken from this illusion and you
understand that black implies white self
implies other life implies death or
should I say death implies life
[Music]
you can feel yourself not as a stranger
in the world not as something here on
probation not as something that has
arrived here by fluke but you can begin
to feel your own existence as absolutely
fundamental what you are basically deep
deep down far far in is simply the
fabric and structure of existence itself
as if you play life on the supposition
that you're a helpless little puppet
we've got involved or if you played on
the supposition that it's a frightful
serious risk and that we really ought to
do something about it and so on it's a
drag there's no point in going on living
unless we make the assumption that the
situation of life is optimal
really and truly we are all in the state
of total bliss and delight but we are
going to pretend we aren't just for
kicks
you play non bliss in order to be able
to experience bliss and you go as far
out as non bliss as you want to go and
when you wake up it'll be great you know
you can slam yourself on the head with a
hammer because it's so nice when you
stop
[Music]
and it makes you realize you see how
great things are when you forget that
that's the way it is and that's just
like black and white you don't know
black unless you know white you don't
know white unless you know black this is
simply fundamental so then here's the
drama my metaphysics that may be
perfectly frank with you ah that there
is the central self you could call it
God you can call it anything you like
and it's all of us it's playing all the
parts of all beings whatsoever
everywhere and anywhere and it's playing
the game of hide-and-seek with itself it
gets lost it gets involved in the forest
out adventures but in the end it always
wakes up and comes back to itself and
when you are ready to wake up you're
gonna wake up and if you're not ready
you're gonna stay pretending that you're
just a little poor little me
if you want to see my take on the dali
lama's top ten rules of success check
the video link right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there a son
says I'm the good person sons a bad
person that doesn't matter solo my own
motivation for thinking